Carnival Cruise Line is apologizing
after another mechanical issue on one of
its ships this time resulting in flooded
cabins dramatic cell phone video shows
water pouring into a hallway in
passenger rooms after a water line broke
last Thursday cruise line says the
incident affected nearly 100 passengers
and damaged 50 rooms on the ship the
ship is called the Carnival Dream Don
Dahler is here with how the crew is
being praised for its quick response Don
good morning good morning the Carnival
dream returned to its homeport in New
Orleans yesterday morning the ship was
five days into its week-long Western
Caribbean voyage with thousands of
passengers on board last Thursday
evening when a fire hydrant pipe burst
crew members responded as steady streams
of water rushed into the ship's ninth
deck hallway all the water started just
like coming up into the room and getting
higher
Marla Haase captured the video on her
cell phone as her room flooded it's like
if you open a fire hydrant wide open
that's how quickly it was coming in the
carnival crew acted quickly shutting off
the water within minutes and forming an
assembly line with buckets carnival says
they replace most of the damaged carpet
just six hours after the incident after
a night of sleeping on a yoga mat in the
ship's paw Hoss was thankful for the
staff and to be back in her room
we felt like royalty we got treated so
wonderfully then rising to the occasion
but this is just the latest in a string
of mechanical incidents for Carnival
Cruise Lines over the past five years
last year at least four different
carnival cruise ships including the
dream reported having engine problems in
2013 the dream got stuck at a Caribbean
port after experiencing generator issues
passengers had to be flown back to
Florida that same year an engine fire
stranded the Carnival Triumph at sea for
four days there was no running water and
hallways were flooded with human waste
despite the dramatic video from last
Thursday's incident carnival tells CBS
News the water main break had no effect
on the safe operation of the ship the
safety and security of our guests and
crew is our top priority
now carnival says passengers affected by
the flooding will receive a full refund
and a 50% credit on any future cruise
the cruise line also offered to pay for
guests flights home if they wanted to
leave early but they say only two out of
nearly 100 took that deal I mean these
things keep happening and you're stuck
on a boat and in the middle of a very
big ocean
yeah water water everywhere escape Don
thank you so much